joe beermaster we have a 2011 nissan
nissan maxima i'm going to just show you
real quick
if your key fob goes dead
there's several ways to start the car
the first trick
these batteries go dead in here you have
enough power to start the car
by touching the key to the button
and it will start foot on the brake
and start that's if your fob is dead
and sometimes it loses programming
so what you have to do if you look on
the dr
on the same thing on the driver's side
left the steering wheel
there's a little port in here see that
little port
you slide the key in and it relearns
now you can also leave the key there
just to start it if you wanted to
just leave it there see car starts
put that in there i just press that so
if you get an
indication on your dash that there's no
key
and it's not communicating you either
want to touch the key
to the button to start it that only
works for so long
you can change the key fob battery which
i do have a
a video on that and then if you need to
sort of reprogram this
because of that you stick it in this
little port and it will reprogram
it and you'll be good to go
here's the little tricks with the nissan
maxima
and it covers multiple multiple years of
the nissan
joe biermaster i hope this helped
little tricks and please subscribe and
give me a thumbs up
you